on passe à présent à la culture avec
notre invité du week end il est artiste
peintre résolument inspiré par les
impressionnistes il s'adonne à capturer
la lumière dans les paysages il expose
ses oeuvres à versailles toute la
semaine prochaine vincent bonjour
bonjour alors ce qui est amusant c'est
quoi des pas vous étiez décorateur de
théâtre oui j'ai commencé par là parce
que c'était j'avais une marraine qui
était qui m'a aidé à pénétrer dans ce
monde du décor de théâtre et c'était un
monde où on apprend vraiment tout de
suite à travailler sur des toiles
immenses qu'ils font 20 mètres de long
sur 10 mètres de haut qui sont cloués au
sol à partir d'une petite maquette dont
on comprend tout de suite conscience de
l'élargissement d'une peinture d'un coup
de traiter un petit truc de 30 sur 30
ans 20 mètres sur 10 ou et c'est très
amusant parce qu'on part avec un balai
au début on pas de ciel en face et on
apprend vraiment son métier on fait du
faux bois ont fait des faux marbre ont
fait des faits du trompe l'oeil on fait
des tas de choses très variées et
vraiment il faut que ça fonctionne parce
qu'ensuite s'est accroché dans les
décors du théâtre là il ya un metteur en
scène qui va vous dire tout ça c'est nul
parce qu'avec sa lumière sa marche plus
faut tout refaire sur place pendant que
les comédiens répètent en dessous et ça
m'a permis de voir des buts et jeanne
moreau enfin des gens comme ça quoi
qu'ils avaient qui avaient mon âge à
l'époque
je connais un petit peu je peignais avec
la peinture à la colle que je piquais
dans le dans l'atelier de de décors
théâtre je n'ai pas les moyens de
m'acheter de la peinture à l'huile dont
je peux y est déjà
bon pas grand chose mais quand est-ce
que c'est fait la bascule réellement la
bascule s'est fait la bascule s'est
faite j'habitais à sont là en espagne et
je peignais beaucoup et puis j'habite
est au milieu d'une colonie allemande
très importante et un jour il ya un
allemand qui est venu me voir qui me dit
mais ce que vous vendez vos tableaux
oui j'ai dit oui et je le dis bah tiens
faisait dimanche je vais faire une expo
à la maison et j'ai fait une expo j'ai
exposé comme ça une trentaine de toiles
et j'en ai vendu 20 gély mais voilà
c'est formidable et à partir de là j'ai
complètement laissé tomber tout ce que
je faisais avant qui était sans intérêt
pour moi et je me suis concentré sur la
peinture donc alors j'ai commencé à
beaucoup voyager
pour peindre exclusivement et là je me
suis aperçu que peindre c'était non
seulement si vous voulez un set et à un
plaisir bien sûr c'était une vocation
c'était un travail mais c'était
essentiellement une concentration totale
c'est à dire que si on peint on est
peintre on n'est pas n'importe quoi puis
un petit peu peintre mais ça s'est
imposé à vous ça s'est imposée à moi si
vous voulez et le double aspect de la
peinture c'est à dire que peindre c'est
très bien mais faire savoir que l'on
pince est aussi important et la basse va
en parler de ce double rôle un il faut
aller aussi commercial quand on est
peintre pour pouvoir en vivre vous avez
quel âge quand vous avez eu ce déclic or
le déclic j'avais j'avais 30 ans passé
j'avais un peu plus de trente ans donc
ça fait maintenant 45 ans que je que je
vis de ma peinture complètement alors on
a vu à l'image pendant que vous parliez
certains de vos tableaux on reconnaît là
l'inspiration des impressionnistes on
pense à pizarro à moi n'est pas
totalement on est totalement pour moi de
là si vous voulez le choc culturel c'est
un des chocs culturels c'est la pi de
mener à orsay devant laquelle je suis
allé la voir dix fois que gilles sioui
pour moi c'est ça la peinture c'est
cette transposition d'un paysage tout à
fait simple est une barrière quelques
arbres de la neige et une pie posé sur
la barrière mais il ya une lumières qui
sort de là il ya une une magie et ça
c'est hallucinant sassoum sy comment on
peut faire ça et c'est ce que je
poursuis en permanence si vous voulez
c'est à dire arriver à dieu c'est la
chose la plus difficile au monde c'est
parce que la lumière change tout le
temps parce qu'elle est fugace selon les
saisons selon les saisons selon la marée
selon les nuages qui passent qui
disparaissent de sol et qui descend la
merde et s'empilent remonte enfin je
veux dire ça change tout le temps et ce
n'est pas frustrant parce que vous
courez après quelque chose en fait
depuis 45 ans
bon ben voilà on pouvait le prendre
comme très frustrant au contraire comme
très satisfaisant à partir du moment où
on a décidé que le plus important
c'était d'arriver à saisir un moment de
lumière et à partir de ce moment là il
ya des choses qui ont bougé au tour les
voiliers qui étaient là sont parties
sont éloignées ça fait rien on peut les
mettre après on peut enlever un arbre
qui gêne on peut on a une liberté totale
dans le respect bien sûr si vous voulez
de
des choses essentielles que sont la
perspective le etc mais on a une liberté
totale de modifier les choses à partir
du moment où on a réussi enfin pour ce
qui me concerne a capté tout un moment
de lumière comme ça magique des fois je
m'arrête au bord de la route dans une
forêt il ya il ya un rayon de ça et qui
passent à travers les arbres je plante
pour cheval et j'attrape ce rayon de
soleil qui disparaît en 10 minutes et
puis ensuite pendant suite je peux
peindre les arbres tranquillement enfin
si vous vous laissez voilà c'est cette
quête alors des fois ça fonctionne très
bien en général ça fonctionne de mieux
en mieux parce que là il se fait l'oeil
s'habitue se forment et puis des fois
ben c'est pas ce que j'espérais mais
vous disais il faut quand même à la base
avoir une certaine technique notamment
pour les perspectives si vous même être
passés par l'atelier absolument je suis
passé par les la grande chaumière et
puis par l'atelier de vivre à hyères et
puis par l'atelier de schultz
oui oui et malheureusement si vous
laissiez n'ai pas trouvé la danse que je
cherchais ce que j'ai cherché j'ai
trouvé avec mon oncle jean rigaud qui
était peintre de la marine et qui m'a
emmené beaucoup peindre avec lui et là
j'ai compris ce que c'était que
justement que saisir quelque chose de
fugaces mais à travers une technique
quand même épuré qui nous encombrent
plus qui vous laisse la liberté et je
voulais revenir sur ce que vous disiez
au début de cet entretien vous parliez
de l'aspect commercial parce que oui
vous faites des tables vous êtes
passionné mais après il faut en vendre
s'il voulait peindre pour point de
l'état de géant des peintres amateurs
qui font ça et qu'ils font très bien
mais ils font ça le samedi le dimanche
en vacances et easy nom de leurs
familles de leurs toiles et c'est très
bien comme ça quand on est peintre
professionnel c'est tout à fait autre
chose là par exemple vient d'avoir une
exposition à dallas au texas vient
d'avoir une exposition à genève il faut
les trouver ces galeries donc faut
d'abord ce que j'ai fait quand je suis
parti je suis parti en floride il ya 35
ans avec une dizaine de petits tableaux
j'ai visité 50 galeries il y en a 49 kim
envieraient il y en a une qui va presser
ça fait 30 ans qu'on travaille ensemble
donc il faut il faut aller se vendre il
faut aller se vendre il faut aller
embêter les galeries faut aller oui il
faut aller il faut organiser des
événements c'est ce que je fais là à
versailles par exemple ou là-haut je ne
travaille pas avec une galerie mais
j'organise tout avec rennes mon épouse
en organise toute l'opération
c'est à dire mille cinq cents
invitations mille affiches à
l'ajustement vallat parlez nous de cette
exposition assez du 17 au 23 septembre à
versailles une exposition intitulée au
fil de l'eau l'eau toujours question de
lumière il est toujours que s'ils ont
surtout de lumière et surtout de la
lumière dans l'eau parce que la lumière
de l'eau si vous voulez là on a été
peinte par exemple quand fillon avait
quatre épouses c'est tous les deux on a
été peintre sur les canaux de bretagne
eh bien ça a été un temps très breton
breton vraiment breton mais c'était
magique c'était magique et une lumière
extraordinaire dans les frondaisons sous
les canaux etc
c'est c'est toujours si vous voulez miss
earth et non pas de chercher un sujet
pour un sujet en sciences à ça va bien
se vendre c'est d'arriver à trouver
quelque chose qui vous correspondent et
ensuite de le 30 décès de le transcender
pour en faire quelque chose de beau de
joyeux moi c'était toujours un peu ma
démarche c'est que la peinture ma
peinture je
veut j'essaye qu'elle soit gay qu'elle
soit joyeuse qu'elle soit heureuse pour
que les gens qui ont acheté un tableau
se disent en partant de travail le matin
sous la pluie ils râlent ils ont quelque
chose qui leur donne un peu de un peu de
joie un peu de soleil en tout cas ça
donne envie de venir la voir cette
exposition du 17 au 23 septembre une
exposition donc on imagine plein de
lumière et de joie comme vous le disiez
merci beaucoup vincent d'être venu vous
ont plu reçus aujourd'hui